نذهب الان الى مصر هناك موضوع شائك جدا
تعيد فتحه بين الحين والاخر حالات سيدات
تعرضت حياتهن للخطر رغم القانون يقفل
رعايه الرعايه الصحيه للمواطنين
ويجرب الامتناع عن تقديمها ترفض مستشفيات
اجراء عمليات بالنساء دون موافقه ازواجهم
طبعا ولايه الجسد مشاهدينا هكذا يسميها
البعض هذه القواعد المتعارف عليها بين
المشافي والاطباء خاصه فيما يتعلق
بالحياه
الانجابيه في نفس الوقت ايضا تجد من يدافع
عن حق الاطباء في الحصول على موافقه الزوج
بحجه الاطباء يواجهون غضب الازواج اذا
اجروا اي جراحه دون موافقتهم او علمهم حتى
راويه يصل الامر الى لجوء بعض الازواج
لمقاضاه الاطباء
والمستشفى خليني اقولك انه سالنا الناس في
مصر ما رايك في قرار بعض المستشفيات بربط
اجراء جراحات للنساء دون الحصول على
موافقه ازواجهم ماذا اجابهم
[موسيقى]
عبر جزم مسافر ولا الوجهه باي مشوار ولا
في حته بعيده ولا في الشغل بعيد وجا لها
مرض مفاجئ هيستنوا رحمه الزوج دي روح بني
ادم ممكن الزوج نفسه ما يكونش عايز يكلف
نفسه او ان هو يدفع حاجه في العمليه ديت
فما يضطر ان هو ما يدخلش زوجته ممكن تكون
واحده عايزه مثلا تساقط بيبي او حاجه من
الحاجات دي مثلا
فده كده المفروض ان هم يستشروا جوزها في
الحاجات دي لازم الزوج يبقى عارف طبعا لان
في عمليات بتبقى محتاجه فعلا ولان هو جزء
كبير جدا من حياتها وجزء اساسي وحد اساسي
في حياتها فلازم يبقى عارف حاجه زي كده
ايه علاقه العمليه الطبيه بموافقه الزوج
فرضا في مشاكل بينها وبين زوجها يعني وهي
محتاجه تعمل عمليه همم شيء غير منطقي
تماما طبعا وغير مقبول وفي نوع من انواع
التقييد حدود المراه
خاصه بعلاقتهم مع بعض الزوج والزوجه دي
قرار صالح صائب في الوقت في المرحله دي
لكن الخلافه كده عمليه ما لهاش علاقه
بينهم بين بعض مفيش مشكله
من القاهره تنضم الينا المخرج جانبين شلبي
ورئيس لجنه اداب المهنه بنقابه الاطباء
سابقا الدكتور خالد سمير اللي يبدا اولا
مع نيفين نيفين صباح الخير
صباح الخير عليكم طبعا ازيكم اهلا وسهلا
خليني ابدا اسال يعني ايه المشكله اذا طلب
الطبيب
موافقه الزوج على اجراء هذه العمليه اليس
الرجل هو المسؤول امام هذا الطبيب عن
الامراه التي ستكون محل نظر العمليه وقد
تكون مخدره وقد تكون لا سمح الله اذا حدث
التفاقمات
اتفضلي ما هو السؤال موجه لك
تمام يعني انا عندي وجهه نظر انا شايفه
انه اي عمليه جراحيه تخص الرجل او المراه
هي حاجه تخص جسده فهو ليه القرار الاول
والاخير فيما يتم في جسده في حين انه لو
الموضوع على المقابل لو الرجل يتم يقوم
بعمل عمليه جراحيه وتمس حياته الزوجيه مع
مراته ما بياخدش اذن يعني القانون هنا
بتاع الولايه يخص ولايه الرجل على المراه
انما مش العكس بحجه انه ده يخص العلاقه
الزوجيه ما بينهم خصوصا في قضيه استئصال
الرحم بتاع المراه يتطلب موافقه الزوج طيب
لو العكس لو الزوج هو هيعمل عمليه جراحيه
والاطباء هم اللي قالوا كده والعمليه دي
هينتج عنها انه هذا الرجل هيبقى ميقدرش
ينجب هل هياخذوا اذن الزوجه طالما هياثر
طالما حجتهم ان هو ده بياثر على العلاقه
الزوجيه مش بياخذوا طالما القانون هنا مش
متساوي يبقى انا ارفضه لا هو يعني
قانون بحد علمنا يعني وحسب ما البحث اللي
عملناه لا يوجد قانون في مصر يجبر الاطباء
والمستشفيات على اخذ موافقه الزوج فيما
يتعلق باي عمليه جراحيه لزوجته حتى وان
كانت في موضوع الصحه الايجابيه ولكن دكتور
خالد انا حابه اسالك طالما مفيش قانون هل
المشكله ما زالت قانونيه ولكن فيما يتعلق
بانه لا يوجد قانون يضبط
طبعا سلوك الزوج او في حال انه تم اجراء
عمليه لزوجته بدون علمه فيذهب للتهجم على
الاطباء وعلى الكادر الطبي في المستشفيات
ولا راضع لذلك فهل اذا وجد قانون بهذا
الشكل تحل المشكله
اولا لازم اوضح للساده المشاهدين ان
الموضوع اكبر من ذلك وليس في مصر وحدها بل
في يعني ايضا على فكره
الولايه القانونيه على الجسد موضوع كبير
جدا لا يخص فقط العلاقه بين الذكر والانثى
في الزواج او غير الزواج احنا عندنا ولايه
قانونيه للانسان على جسده في حالات فقد
الاهليه زي المسجون قال له الحق في ان هو
يمضي
كونسنت يعني موافقه مستنيره لاجراء بتر
مثلا او فعل في جسده اثناء فتره سجن ولا
لا عندنا مشكله الانسان بعد وفاته احنا
عندنا في مصر بنحاول ان احنا نعمل نبدا في
زرع الاعضاء من المتوفين وهناك حتى الان
ما زالت مشاكل يقال ان ورثه من يتبرع
باعضاعه بعد الوفاه يمكنه الاعتراض على
ذلك هل الجسد يورث
ثم ناتي الى مشاكل مثلا زي الاجهاض
الاجهاض مشكله في كل انحاء العالم تعريفه
ومن له الولايه القانونيه على الجنين هل
هو للاب ام للامه هل هي حريه للام في
اجهاض نفسها ولا لا يعني فكره الاستئصال
الرحم كموضوع هو موضوع صغير جدا جدا في
مشكله كبيره جدا
اذا تكرمت نركز عليه الان
لماذا يعني هذه الطلبات
طبعا زي ما حضراتكم قلتم هو لا يوجد قانون
لكن هناك سوابق قضائيه هناك كثير من
الازواج رفع وقضايا ضد اطباء وتم الحكم
فيها لصالح هؤلاء الازواج انهم لم يحصلوا
على موافقتهم في استئصال رحم او مبايض او
شيء في زوجته من زوجتهم ثم هناك حتى
الزوجات التي راغبنا في ذلك في مرحله ما
اثناء خلافها مع الزوج عندما يصطلح
الطرفان قد يتضامنان ضد الطبيب يعني ليه
هو ليش الطلب يعني طالما لا يوجد قانون
وطالما ان المواطن المصري ذكرا كان ام
انثى والطرفين متساويين امام امام القانون
وفي الدستور لهم نفس الواجبات والحقوق
لماذا هذه التفرقه
كما طرحتها الاستاذه نيفين دمل عندما لا
يوجد نص عندما لا يوجد نص قانوني بيترك
للقاضي يعني لضمير القاضي الحكم في
القضايا الازواج بيرفعوا قضايا ويحكم
لصالحهم احيانا حتى في عدم وجود قانون
الاحكام القضائيه هي اللي بتحط يعني قواعد
تجعل الاطباء وقانونيه طيب دكتور هل لو
عكسنا الوضع فمثلا هل هل جرى او تستطيع
المراه ان ترفع قضيه على المستشفى لانهم
طلبوا موافقه الزوج وبالتالي عرضوا حياتها
للخطر يعني في الجهه المقابله لهذه
السوابق القانونيه التي تتحدث عنها من
يعني الاحكام القضائيه
يعني انا لم اشاهد انا شفت سابق قضائيه من
من الازواج لم اشاهد قبل ذلك دعوه من سيده
ترفع ضد مستشفى انها طلب منها ذلك ولو
اخذت احكام قضائيه بعدم لزوم اخذ تعهد من
الزوج في بعض العمليات الجراحيه الخاصه
بالولايه
انشاء المشتركه طبعا اذا كان هناك سابق
قانونيه واحكام نهائيه تكون قواعد مثل
القانون تماما
استاذه نيفين يعني حتى نعطيك الحق بالرد
على كل ما سمعتيه ماذا تقولين
اولا قانون الولايه
الجسديه على الجسد او انه يبقى في ولايه
على التحفيل تحكم على الجسد الدكتور ذكر
ان هو له تفاصيل كتير جدا انا هنا بتكلم
في نقطه الست العاقله الراشده البالغه انا
امراه دلوقتي بدفع ضرايب وبطلع رخصه قياده
في الدوله اللي انا عايشه فيها بالظبط ليه
يبقى في شخص اخر ايا كانت علاقتي بيه ان
هو يبقى له ولايه على جسدي ايا كانت
علاقتي بيه سواء زوجي او ابويا او اي حاجه
طالما نعطله يعني الدكتور ذكر انه الولايه
تكون مثلا على قانون هنا ممكن يتكلم لو
هذا الشخص توفى او هذا الشخص غير عاقل او
طفل صغير او رجل في السجن انما انا بقول
انا ست عاقله دلوقتي ليه في عمليه جراحيه
مثلا زي القضيه الشائكه اللي كنا بنتكلم
فيها الادب يعني قضيه مريم الست دي كان
بقى لها اربع شهور بتموت عندها نزيف
دكاتره رفضوا لما راحت المستشفى
همم ان هم يعملوا لها العمليه لولا ان
الموضوع طلع على السوشيال ميديا انقذوها
احنا الساده نيفين يعني خلص وقتنا خلص
ان الموضوع
الاصابع يجب ان توجه الى المشرع وليس
الاطباء المشرع هو الذي لديه قصور لم يسد
هذا هذه الثغرات القانونيه شكرا جزيلا
للمخرجه نيفين شلبي وكذلك لرئيس لجنه اداب
المهنه بنقابه الاطباء سابقا الدكتور خالد
سمير شكرا جزيلا لكما
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات